[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAWAD KHAN: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to our session
for understanding
the use cases of unstructured
data in health care.
My name is Jawad
Khan, and I'm Director
of Knowledge Management and
Data Services at Rush University
Medical Center.
My primary role at Rush is to
store, analyze, and provide
insights to the hospital
or hospital system.
I have about a dozen
awesome data engineers
and data scientists
who work with my team.
And that's what we
do for a living--
store data and analyze data
for health care insights.
I welcome you on behalf of
both of my co-presenters.
Dave, you want to
introduce yourself, please.
DAVID PATTERSON: Yeah, sure.
My name is David Patterson.
I'm a senior principal
with Maven Wave.
We're a premier
partner of Google.
We've been working
with Jawad and his team
for the past six
to seven months.
So excited to talk
to you guys today.
VASUDHA GUPTA: Hi, everyone.
My name is Vasudha Gupta.
I am a customer
engineer with Google.
And I've been working with
the Rush and Maven Wave
team on some of the
interesting use cases
that we are doing at Rush.
Just kind of one housekeeping
item before we get started.
We do have a Dory
link that's really
a link on your app to allow
you to submit questions anytime
during the presentation.
We'll have a Q&A for
10 minutes at the end.
So it would be great if you can
submit your questions as you're
thinking about it during the
presentation, or at the end,
you can also come up and
speak it to the mic as well.
JAWAD KHAN: Great.
Thank you.
Like I said, the
idea of this session
was to primarily share
with all of you what
do we do with unstructured
data in relation
specifically to the EHR, the
electronic health records?
How much unstructured
data do we collect?
And what do we do with
the unstructured data?
How do we store the
unstructured data?
How do we retrieve
the unstructured data?
And what type of
analysis we do provide.
That was the idea
of this session.
But before we get there, let me
share a few things about Rush
University Medical Center.
We are a very historical
institute in Chicago?
Anybody from Chicago
in the crowd here?
There you go.
So a few folks here.
You all may know about Rush.
We are three hospitals,
one out in Copley,
one in Rush Oak Park, and one
right in west side of downtown.
We have more than 30-plus
outpatient clinics.
We are a Rush University
for medical school.
We are a four-time, actually,
magnet nursing school.
All you need to know about Rush
is available on the website.
You can go find out more.
But this slide actually talks
about what Rush is doing
and how we are at the forefront
of making an effort at least
to transform health care.
Rush was, since our
CIO, Dr. Shafiq Rab,
joined us two years ago, we
are the first institution
to implement a full closed-cycle
social determinants of health.
We are very engaged with the
community where we are today.
And we have a system where now
people coming into our center
are screened for
social determinants.
We refer them
electronically to a source,
and the data flows
back into the EMR.
So first institution
that did a full lifecycle
of social determinants
of health.
Rush is, like I said,
we are first institution
to implement managing meds
through a mobile application,
nurse documentation.
We were the first institution
to receive-- or one
of the three institutions
to receive a state
seven in analytics.
And it's pretty businesslike.
But the idea was
essentially to show
what we are doing, like I
said, to transform health care.
Even an institution like
us, having said that,
or continuously is
struggling with what do we
do with the data, specifically
with the unstructured data?
And is anybody in
the audience here
who works in the health
care specifically,
health care vertical?
There are a few people.
Oh, there are quite
a few people, great.
How many of you are in the
provider space, in the hospital
space?
Got it.
There are a few.
If you look under the hood of
what's in a hospital system
or specifically behind an
electronic health record,
it is this.
It's thousands of
tables, a lot of data,
mostly highly normalized,
very hard to find
any one-to-one relationships.
And then when you compound that
with a problem like this, where
there is data everywhere
else, in fact, only about,
I would say 20%, 30% of the
data that we analyze and store
comes from the
electronic health record,
but there is everywhere else.
It's outside the EMR.
It's in our ERP systems,
in our networking systems.
And believe it or
not, all the data
is still relevant
to health care.
It is still relevant to how we
provide care to our patients.
So we are very interested in
putting the data together,
putting it in a common platform,
and trying to solve health care
problems with the data.
In short, health care
data is classic big data.
It comes from all
different angles.
It has veracity, it has
velocity, and you name it.
So what are we doing with it?
Specifically, like I said,
the idea of this presentation
was to talk about
unstructured data,
and what are we doing
with unstructured data?
As you may know--
because people specifically
who are in health care
and people who are specifically
working in the hospital field,
you may know that out-of-box,
we don't necessarily
have solutions to easily
analyze health care data.
An EHR doesn't come with
an NLP, so to say, right?
We would have to implement that.
We would have to
extract the data.
We would have to manage the data
and implement a solution that
does analyze unstructured data.
Doctors like to type notes.
In a typical EHR
implementation, there
are more than 100-plus notes.
There are progress notes.
There are pathology notes.
There are nurses' notes.
There are notes everywhere.
In fact, even in a
most simple statement,
like a nurse would
be typing and saying
does this person-- oh, I receive
a drug, like I'm saying there,
Sally is getting
drug from a friend.
When you get that
medication ontology
and you understand
what those drugs are
and how do they line up
to the patient's problems,
it's a very difficult problem
to solve because those insights
are not readily available.
So what do we do with
unstructured data
to be able to solve problem?
What are you doing today?
And like I said, it is not
really necessarily easy.
And any solution that you read
about unstructured data or NLP
having done on health
care is mostly still,
today, living on
the research side.
Not very many implementations
or not very many
solutions or products have
come on the commercial side,
and that's what Rush,
specifically our team
is focused on doing.
I have some folks
from my team here
who have been
living and breathing
NLP and unstructured data
for the last two years.
Guys, you want to raise
your hands, please?
Accolades to them.
These are amazing engineers.
They have learned so much
about medical ontologies,
so much about how to understand
what those ontologies are
and how they relate to
solving medical problems,
it's incredible.
I encourage all of
you to talk to them.
I am just one person
representing all the work
that we have done over
two years with NLP data.
So in short, it is very
difficult to extract the data.
It is very difficult
to store the data
in a comprehensive solution,
and be able to provide solution.
It is very, very
costly, in fact.
Like I said, we have spent
a good two years, a good two
years to extract the data from
an EMR, store it in a format
that we can understand
in a single platform
and be able to analyze it.
What does the data
look like today?
An average provider
note, specifically,
if you look at it is
about 45 kilobytes.
And we collect about 8.5
million notes per year.
If you do two years--
when we started the project--
why am I saying
two years here is
because when we started this
NLP project in our institution
first, our focus was to
look at at least two years
worth of notes, right?
Historically go back and
extract two years' worth of data
and analyze it and see
what insights we can find.
And sure enough, just those
two years' worth of notes
were so big that our data
centers couldn't handle it.
Or we were not able to
store it and process it
in a single infrastructure.
So we had to look
at other solutions
to be able to do that.
And now, because what we
achieved with finding insights,
and I'm going to talk about
that in a few minutes,
with two years' worth of data,
the institution has asked us
now to expand that search,
go back to extracting 10
years' worth of data.
And that literally will end
up in petabytes of data.
It's really a problem to solve.
How do we actually
analyze all the data
and be able to provide
meaningful insights
for the institution?
The use cases that
we specifically
started with for
unstructured data
is around adenoma,
as adenoma detection
is a very important measure.
It's a CMS measure.
It gives our GI department--
if the doctors, for example,
if the patients come in
and they're not screening
the patients properly
in colonoscopy as for colon
cancer, it's a big deal.
It's a measure that gets
measured by the CMS,
like I said.
So we started doing our
NLP with adenoma detection,
meaning we were extracting
all the pathology
and the provider notes
to be able to identify
where the doctors were
typing for adenomas.
And we were able to provide
a dashboard straight off
of the data for them
to be able to see.
We were successful in providing
a use case for adenoma, where
now providers are actively
using a dashboard off
of our unstructured data
in real time in memory
to be able to make decisions
about which patients to be
called back into the health care
or into the clinical pathway
to prevent people from
getting colon cancer.
So this is a big deal.
It is a big deal both from
a regulatory point of view
for the institution
to be compliant
of a specific measure.
It's a big deal for
patients, because we
are in the business of
providing best health
care for our patients.
The second was
about H&P, history
and physical for the providers.
History and physical is
also a regulatory measure.
So to be specific
about it, so to explain
what it means for
people who may not know,
is if I am going in a
surgery, for example,
and if my history and physical
is not complete in my EHR 48
hours prior to the surgery, that
surgery needs to be canceled.
If any institution
fails to do that,
then it's a bad mark on you.
You can get audited,
and it would
be exception for institution.
So we cannot make that happen.
And for an institution
of our size
with three different
hospitals, making
sure every surgery has every
history and physical completed
manually is a big deal.
It actually required a
staff of three nurses
to go through all the
history and physical
to make sure it's complete.
Well, we were able to use our
NLP engine, our AI platform,
to be able to
comprehensively identify
and score history and
physicals which were complete
and which were not complete.
And the guy who did this here
is [? Darpin ?] [? Amin. ?] I
mean, [? Darpin ?] was
instrumental in figuring out
an AI solution, full end-to-end,
where we extract the histories
and physicals from our EMR,
we run it through our NLP,
and we make sure that the
history and physical is
complete before we
provide it, again,
dashboard with the end users
to be able to recall either
history or physical are
completed before the process.
So it's a huge, huge case--
amazingly valuable
for the institution.
We were able to save
time, money, and resources
for the institution.
And the third one,
last but not the least
is clinical documentation
improvement.
Like I was giving an example
of where very mundane notes can
be typed about medication,
about health conditions,
about comorbidities, they're
not readily available
unless somebody is able
to go through those notes
and extract those insights.
Clinical documentation
improvement is very important,
one, to make sure
that the patients,
we are able to provide better
health care, proper health
care, relevant health
care to the patients.
And at the same time, again,
it helps the institution
to affect and address
the bottom line.
That is, if you are
in the payer space,
you know what I'm talking about.
If you are in the
insurance space,
you know what I'm talking about.
If you send a claim for
the patient's record
or the transaction without
proper documentation,
then guess what?
It gets denied.
It gets rejected.
It gets delayed.
So it is extremely important
for us to be able to make sure
that the clinical documentation
improvement is in place.
And in short of having
everything completed manually,
we developed a solution
that is 100% based
on data extraction,
unstructured data
to improve our clinical
documentation improvement.
All the use cases
that are talked about,
obviously, requires
both processing the data
in the back end, running
through an NLP engine,
matching with medical ontology,
sometimes general ontology,
sometimes very specific
to specific service lines,
be it cancer, be it hip
and joint, what not.
And on top of that,
we have to make sure
that we are able to provide
the solutions to the end users
to be able to consume the
information that the engine has
provided, right?
Without that, it
becomes very difficult.
And all these are definitely
important problems,
but they are very hard problems.
We often run into
people, vendors
who talk about having one
solution in one place,
and to this day, we
haven't found it.
It's very, very
difficult. You always
have to put pieces
together to be
able to solve the problem
with unstructured data.
And anybody who is familiar
with working with file system
databases and extracting the
data in the native format,
storing it, it's a challenge.
And if I'm doing
it on a daily basis
to operationalize
something, it's a challenge.
These problems are
definitely not easy to solve,
but they are very,
very important.
And if anybody, in
my opinion, is not
dealing with
unstructured data that
is available in the institution,
in any health care institution,
then we are not looking at
one of the key components
of the data that
we need to analyze.
So the story that you need
to take away from today
is that as an
institution, if you're not
tackling unstructured
data, then you're leaving
a big piece of puzzle behind.
It is very, very important
that institution like ours,
who are primarily responsible
in providing best health care,
should 100% look to
solve unstructured data,
analyze it, solve
it, and provide it
as a solution for
the institutions.
Having said that, the
challenges are unlimited.
There is many more use
cases that can be done.
Even today, after what we
have done for past two years,
we still have
disjoint data sets.
There is unstructured
data, like I
said, in our ERPs that
need to be brought back
that will be consumed.
There are all
types of solutions,
and we are slowly and
definitely working
towards solving those problems.
This slide specifically was to
help you understand what it is
and show you how
we have achieved
some of those use cases.
What we wanted to do,
what we have learned--
definitely, to be able
to solve or put together
a solution using
unstructured data,
we have to make sure that we're
able to solve the problem, one,
by collaboration
internally and externally
with the partners and the
people within the resources.
We have to make sure
that we are able to,
like I said, to provide
notes to the end users that
is intuitive for them to
be able to consume the data
and be able to work with the
data that we have provided
and the insights.
How do they do
interventions with the data
that we are providing?
What actions they are
able to take with the data
you're providing.
These things cannot
be isolated or siloed.
You have to put that
together as you are thinking
through these problems.
The second is scale.
How do we scale this problem?
How do we, like I was saying,
go from two years to 10 years?
And how do we do it in a
cost-effective fashion, right?
And single source of truth.
This continues to be a problem.
We have tried so many
different solutions.
And I can speak to you
very transparently,
that when we first started on
this journey two years ago,
four or five months within
the project, we failed.
We miserably failed
because we were not
able to properly
implement a solution that
was cost effective.
The costs that we were incurring
for storing and processing
the data was growing
significantly.
There was a question
about why not do it,
and then how was I supposed
to do it in the cloud?
There were so many different
problems that we had to solve.
So it's definitely worth trying
something, failing early,
and fixing it as you go about.
That's the lesson
that we learned
and wanted to share with you.
What now?
So what do we do?
Like I said, we want to go
into the space of pop health.
We want to be able to do a lot
of KPI performance improvement
using this data.
We have a lot
novel cases that we
want to implement
as we move forward.
Maybe this is time
for us to talk
about how we are partnering
with Google and Maven Wave
to sort of solve this problem.
Like I said, unstructured data
obviously is very important
to solve, but you cannot solve
that before actually also
mating that with
the structured data.
And how we are using or
leveraging GCP today,
I think Vasu will
talk about that.
Vasu, please.
Yes.
VASUDHA GUPTA: All right.
Thanks, Jawad.
So Jawad hit on kind
of the business problem
that we were really looking
at at Rush and really kind
of this unique problem of
melding the unstructured data
with structured data.
What I'm going to talk
a little bit about
is really how Google Cloud
Healthcare and the products
and solutions that we offer
was instrumental in making
this kind of business problem
and solving this business
problem.
And really the focus of my--
or the focus of my part
of the presentation
will really be on the Cloud
Healthcare API and the Clinical
Data Warehouse, which were two
of the unique products that
were critical and integral
to really building out
this end-to-end pipeline for
solving the business problem.
And Cloud Healthcare API
being that key mechanism
for ingesting and storing
and analyzing of the data
and then clinical
data warehouse as you
look at different sources and
all of these disparate data
formats coming together,
how you really kind of put
all that together
and really build
this notion of a clinical
data warehouse sitting
on top of something
like BigQuery
for the petabytes amount of data
that you're looking to handle
So what is the Cloud
Healthcare API?
So it's a solution that's being
built by the Cloud Healthcare
Team that really speaks,
understands, talks the health
care-specific vernacular and
health care-specific language.
It's really meant to accelerate
your ingestion of your data,
your storage of the data,
the analysis of the data,
specific to health care.
In its current
state right now, it
supports DICOM,
HL7v2, and FHIR, which
stands for Fast Healthcare
Interoperability Resources.
And since there are so many
people in the crowd that
are from the health
care industry,
this should not be a surprise.
And if you look at sort of a
trend within the health care
industry and the fact that
there are so many disparate data
formats, there is kind of a move
in the industry in health care
to really standardize
to adopting
FHIR as that gold standard.
But like I said,
the Healthcare API
supports all these
different three data
types in its native form
within the Healthcare API.
What does the Healthcare API
comprise of in a nutshell?
So really, I kind of boil it
down to three main components.
At the center of
it all is really
a secure, high-performant
repository
that exists for DICOM,
HL7v2, and FHIR.
So there's a FHIR
store, an HL7v2 store,
and a DICOM store that exists
within the Healthcare API.
And then wrapped
around that repository
is a series of both
admin and access APIs
that are compliant with
health care data standards
and really allow you
to talk that health
care-specific
language and access
that data that's
sitting in those stores.
And then third is really a suite
of integrations and capability
that allow you to do the most
with your health care data.
So a combination of the
repositories, the APIs,
and the integrations,
whether it be
integrations to
your systems that
is ingesting the
data or integrations
outside to external applications
to send the data out,
Healthcare API provides
those capabilities
and that's why it's a unique
and compelling product
and also why it was
critical in kind
of solving this
problem of ingesting
this unstructured data
which, in this case for Rush,
was within FHIR messages that we
ingested from the different EMR
systems.
So if you kind of look at
the clinical data mapping
workflow in its kind
of entirety, the data,
like I said, it could
be in different formats.
It can be in HL7v2, FHIR.
It can also be in some of the
other non-standard formats,
like CSV, XML, so and so forth.
So as you're looking
to ingest these data
across from different
systems and different formats
and really trying to build
this sort of central place
in storing that data, you kind
of go to the Healthcare API.
And like I said, there's a FHIR
store within the Healthcare API
that allows you to
capture that data.
But there's like a middle
transformation layer, right?
So you've got all these
different sources,
and especially if
you're looking at doing
cross-modality analysis across
the different data sources,
that transformation layer to
convert HL7 to FHIR or CSV
to FHIR, really allowing
that and capturing
that data in something
like a FHIR store
is that something that Cloud
Healthcare API does really
well.
And then once the data is
there and the Cloud Healthcare
API in that FHIR store,
the data can be exposed
to external applications.
So an example could be
an application sitting
on top of App Engine
or even the data
could be exposed as
APIs through something
like Apigee and so and so forth.
So that data, again,
can be exposed
to external applications.
And then also, if you're
looking at, again,
melding that unstructured and
structured data, if you want
that structured analysis of
that data-- in this case,
we had notes that we were
ingesting as FHIR messages,
and we wanted to create a schema
that was standard for analysis.
The data can also be stored
in something like BigQuery.
Or even, if you want to
do machine learning models
on top of the data, than
really using a product
like cloud and meld engine to do
some of that machine learning.
So all in all, if
you kind of look
at that end-to-end
workflow, from the ingestion
to the standardization
to really exposing
the data in different
ways, that's
something that we built as the
common architecture pattern
when we were working with Rush.
One of the other capabilities
that the Healthcare
API provides is the ability to
react to data near real time.
And what I mean
by that is there's
a strong integration between the
Cloud Healthcare API and Cloud
Pub/Sub, which is our real-time
messaging and event streaming
service.
And anytime a data lands in the
FHIR store or the DICOM store,
it essentially sends
a notification message
to Pub/Sub.
And that could be a trigger
for different things
that you do downstream,
again, whether it be rendering
to certain applications or maybe
a cloud functions routine that,
in turn, executes a
machine learning model,
the output of which can
then be integrated back
into your external application.
So this kind of
powerful notion of being
able to react to data
real time, to think
about real-time inferences
as you start building
your machine learning models
is a really compelling story
with the Healthcare API.
Another capability
that is provided
is the ability to de-identify
your FHIR and DICOM resources.
So within the Cloud
Healthcare API,
there is a de-identify
call that you can make.
And depending on the
attributes that you specify,
you can configure
that and it will
de-identify those
specific attributes
and create essentially another
version of your data set
or store and capture that within
another FHIR store or DICOM
store, and so on and so forth.
And this is
applicable, again, even
on the DICOM images,
the FHIR resources,
and so on and so forth.
And then last but not least,
another key capability
is the ability to export
this FHIR and DICOM
metadata to BigQuery.
So like, again, coming
back to Jawad's point,
this notion of really
being able to analyze
this unstructured data
and make sense of it
and capturing it in
something like BigQuery
can be extremely powerful.
One of the things
that's not on here
but that's something that's
being released really
soon is Cloud
Healthcare API is also
going to be able to support
real-time streaming of data
to BigQuery.
So that's also coming.
So in the future,
essentially, as the data
is coming to Healthcare API,
without this export call,
the data can be streamed
into BigQuery directly.
So again, kind of in summary,
this Cloud Healthcare API
was central and core to
building this pipeline
and ingesting these FHIR,
these unstructured data
and the clinical notes
embedded in the FHIR messages
for our solution.
But kind of shifting
gears a little bit
and talking more on the
structured data side,
again, if you think about
going back to this idea
that you have data coming
from different sources
and different formats,
both historical data
and incremental data,
you want to map it
to some sort of a common
data model, right?
There's a lot of
different data models
that exist within the
health care industry.
So thinking about kind of your
OMOP data models, CDISC or even
a consistent and structured
FHIR schema that,
again, is that middle layer,
the mapping and transformation
layer that becomes critical.
So how do I map HL7 to FHIR?
Or how do I map CSV to FHIR?
So one of the other products
that the Google Health
Team is investing
heavily in is really
building this mapping
and transformation layer
to make this Clinical Data
Warehouse solution really
effective and really efficient.
And the idea behind
that is going
to be building of a mapping
and a configuration tool that
allows you to map between
different data formats
and provides you
this UI and GUI-like
interface to allow you to map
between different formats.
And we're interjecting
that layer
with a lot of machine
learning capabilities.
So how does that mapping
layer become smarter over time
as you look to transform and
build these target schemas
and build this notion of
a clinical data warehouse
on BigQuery?
And kind of taking
it one level further,
if you think about what you
really want to do from--
you've got all these
different sources.
You've got all these
different types of data.
How do I really do
cross-modality analysis?
How do I blend, for
instance, maybe genomics data
in the future to the data that's
coming from FHIR, HL7, DICOM,
so and so forth?
So again, thinking
about the pipeline
ingesting the data
from EHR systems,
or your PAC systems into the
Healthcare AI specific stores,
capturing that data in
BigQuery, performing
certain transforms and
different analytics on it,
and really creating these
ready-to-consume schemas, which
could be, again, OMOPs,
custom-made schemas,
FHIR schemas, so and
so forth, and having it
to the end user for different
analytics and visualization use
cases is really
our kind of vision
for this cross-modality
analysis and really this ability
to build this clinical
data warehouse in BigQuery.
So I'll just wrap up by saying
that, again, Cloud Healthcare
API and the Clinical
Data Warehouse
were key health care products
and solutions that we
kind of considered as we were
building this architecture.
And I'm going to
hand it over to Dave,
who's going to talk about
the end-to-end solution
architecture.
DAVID PATTERSON: Thank you.
Vasu.
All right.
So I get to, hopefully,
bring some of the solution
together and link the
Healthcare API back
to the message and challenges
that we were having at Rush.
So what I want to show
you is how we can combine
the Healthcare API, along with
a natural language processing
engine running on GCP to
unlock key health care
use cases that
Jawad referred to.
That includes document integrity
checking, clinical decision
support, public health
records, and disease trends.
Before I get to the
solution, I wanted
to give you or share
with you the journey
that Maven Wave and
Rush has been on.
When Maven Wave
works with clients,
we typically
recommend four phases
for moving workloads to GCP.
The first one is assess.
So this is when
you're prototyping,
you're experimenting,
and really trying
to figure out if GCP is the
right fit for your solution.
The second is planning.
This is setting
up infrastructure,
getting projects
organized, setting up
billing, and most importantly,
picking your first workload.
Moving on to deployment-- this
is implementation, migration,
of the workload, and
finally operationalizing,
which is standing up a program
with your kind of future work
backlog.
Key throughout this process
is to tightly align scope
to business value
and security needs.
Rather than trying to build the
perfect technology platform,
really kind of quickly
deliver business value
to build credibility
in the organization.
So where we're at
with Rush-- we are
through the first deployment
and working with them
to define future workloads that
Jawad will talk through here
in a little bit.
All right.
So let's get on to
document coding basics.
So back to what Jawad
was referring to
in terms of getting structure
out of unstructured patient
documents.
So what are the basic
building blocks?
The first one is
applying core NLP.
And this is kind of the
standard technologies that
are used across natural
language technologies,
but that includes parts
of speech extraction,
context, negation detection, and
most importantly for this use
case is the named
entity recognition.
That's a challenge in
medical or clinical notes,
which makes the
second step critical,
which is applying
medical vocabularies.
And these are
vocabularies that are
curated by international
health organizations.
The two that we used in
this solution was SNOMED CT.
That includes 300,000
coded medical concepts,
including diagnoses, clinical
findings, body structures,
and observations.
The second is RxNORM,
which is geared
towards pharmaceuticals
and links
to common drug vocabularies.
So the third building block
is taking our coded documents,
and like Vasu was mentioning,
getting them stored
in a clinical data warehouse.
So let's look at an example
of what this looks like.
Here, you can see
the precise codings
that have been extracted
from a fragment
of a clinical narrative.
And it's these
precise codings that
really form the foundation
for cross-patient analytics.
All right.
So in terms of our
solution approach, first,
we wanted to land raw,
unstructured patient data
in the Healthcare FHIR store.
So we didn't use a great
amount of the data structures
available in the API, but we
did get a lot of acceleration
just from using and not
having to redefine a schema
as we're moving raw data
from the EMR into Google.
Second were the
security controls
that were already in place.
Second step was establish
an autoscaling medical NLP
microservice platform.
We did that on
Kubernetes engine.
Third was leveraging data
flow and beam pipelines
for data orchestration.
And then finally, creating
a clinical data warehouse
in BigQuery.
So establishing the
NLP core, fortunately,
there's been a lot of good
work, I think, Jawad mentioned,
in the research hospitals,
research organizations,
around this problem set.
So we were able to use two
open-source technologies,
CTAKES and QuickULMS, and then
augment that with some custom
rule-based NLP for Rush.
The bad news is that some
of these technologies
have evolved over the
course of a decade or more.
So they're monolithic.
They had varied
support for APIs.
So the second step was to
modernize and normalize
those applications.
So we performed
some optimizations
and threading
around performance,
and then we implemented
web-friendly APIs
in JSON and GRPC.
Finally, containerizing and then
moving to Kubernetes engine.
And this was key to providing
that kind of autoscaling
capability and cost control
that Rush was looking for.
So putting it all together--
so working from the left, we
sourced unstructured patient
records from the EMR.
We landed them in
the Healthcare API.
We leveraged some of the event
triggering that Vasu mentioned
to trigger real-time data
flows, to then apply the NLP
coding, and finally, storing
that in a scalable data
warehouse built on BigQuery.
And that sets us up nicely for
future ML workloads as well as
descriptive analytics
and data exploration.
Some future workloads-- we
plan to take imaging data
from the PAC system
DICOM files and move them
to the Healthcare API,
claims data and ERP also
to kind of round out operations
and kind of do cross-analytics
with that patient data.
Here's a different view
of the same architecture.
We can see EMR, some of
the future data sources
at Rush, patient
data storage in FHIR,
filtering and
parsing in data flow.
We've got a medical NLP
on Kubernetes engine.
Finally, moving that
into a Clinical Data
Warehouse on BigQuery.
All right.
I think I'm going
to hand it back over
to Jawad for some takeaways
and road map items.
JAWAD KHAN: Thank you, Dave.
So like Vasu and
Dave mentioned, we
started with just looking
at unstructured data,
meaning we're specifically
focusing on just the notes
that we were extracting.
But there is several
modalities that we are now
starting to work
on because we have
confidence the architecture
seems to be pretty stable.
And I think they really do
expand to other modalities.
And the first one
that we're going
to look at, as like
Dave talked about,
is to connect our PAC server
to the GCP environment
and be able to directly query
the data from the PAC server
into a DICOM store and
then have machine learning
models run on that imaging.
The second use case is to do
very similar to PAC server
but more focus on
the cancer side,
to actually do some mammograms.
And there is a solution
already out there
that we use today,
which is on-prem to do
a real-time AI on a mammogram.
So if somebody comes
in for a mammogram,
the image gets into
the PAC server,
and we immediately run
it through a ML model
to sort of annotate
it to see if it
is positive/negative for
breast cancer, right?
Those cases are running
today, on-prem today,
but it's very isolated
to just mammograms.
But we are expanding it to
other imaging solutions.
And the idea is to be able
to do that over the cloud
because obviously, it would have
to scale for other use cases.
The third is our
clinical data model today
is completely in
our data centers,
in our on-prem data centers.
Both the transactional
and operational databases,
the data warehouses are all
within our data centers today
and our unstructured
or advanced analytics
is all happening in cloud.
So there is a sort
of a disconnect.
Every time we have to
bring clinical data
to be able to correlate with
our advanced analytic solutions,
we are having to either
batch those queries back
into the cloud or bring some
of the unstructured data
that we have now converted
into structured data
down into where
the warehouses are
and be able to do analytics.
But ideally, there is--
I think the time is
right for us to be
able to look at those data
structures and data warehousing
solutions very carefully now.
And we are seriously
giving it a very hard look
to see if we can implement a
common clinical data model that
supports both advanced analytics
and our VI solutions in cloud
type of structure.
There are not many very
well-designed clinical data
models that are out there.
We use-- I don't know if you
guys are familiar with OMOP.
We use OMOP as a data model
for some of the use cases,
but it doesn't necessarily
support outside
of just transactions, right?
So we have other
clinical use cases
that we want to expand
the data models to.
And we really want a
true representation
of the clinical data
model looks like,
including the patient finances,
including corporate finances,
and including our
clinical outcomes.
We are very closely
looking at, like I said,
to move that into our GCP or
BigQuery type of environment
to be able to leverage both
structured and unstructured
data.
Last but not the least,
it is of high interest,
I mean, it's one of the
institutional priorities
to be able to develop
a search solution.
Today, it is very difficult
to search within the EHRs,
electronic health records.
You can probably
do a search, even
with a third-party solution
across the patient charts
or maybe just looking at the
patient chart vertically,
you're able to search
for comorbidities
and some of the
diseases that you're
looking for specifically.
But doing across the EMR
is a bit not there yet.
So the provider is not able
to look his or her enpanelment
in a very comprehensive way to
be able to identify solutions.
And then to make
it more complex,
what if you have
more than one EHR?
How are you then able to
search across all the EHRs
if the provider is
seeing a patient, say,
for example, at our satellite
location and a different EHR.
And the provider, now comes back
to the hospital as an attendee.
He has this patient here.
He's not able to really
search comprehensively
across all system.
So the idea is to, again,
bring all this data
together in a common clinical
data model, have unstructured
data insights available
in a single place
where we can do searches.
We have a name for it.
We are calling it
single BigQuery
that we want to implement
as part of the EHR solution.
[MUSIC PLAYING]